il ya quelques ann et benjamin castaldi
a appelé faustine bollaert pour lui
demander de l'épouser de divorcer du
staff aaa pour la draguer pour lui
demander de l'argent pour l'insulter
alors sur benjamin vous n'êtes pas aller
vite mais maghreb d'où la draguer et
vale pour ce que tâchent il est non
c'est pourquoi alors et sénateurs que je
ne connaissais pas elle est revenu
récemment sur le jour elles avaient
infiltré les castings de love story 2
elle en a profité pour évoquer la
réaction de benjamin castaldi quand il
l'a appris s'ils savaient pas du tout
mais benjamin après vous êtes comme vous
êtes bah oui ça vous rappelle quelqu'un
qui vous alors je vous dis la vérité
oui franchement je n'ai jamais jamais
faits vécus boeuf ah oui ouais bah moi
si mais non mais non mais c'est un héros
très honnêtement jamais oublier
complètement la faire non plus vous
l'aimez bien comme ça elle m'a appelé
pour mieux je suis désolé je voulais pas
créer de polémique les détails et aucun
problème et c'est vrai que sûrement
qu'elle est à l'époque j'ai d'une
insulte et parce que ça avait demandé
alors on va on va revenir sur l'histoire
benjamin regarde c'est ce qu'on appelle
une bombe à retardement un vieux dossier
qui traînait dans les fonds de tiroirs
de l'animatrice faustine bollaert
qu'elle a décidé de balancer aujourd'hui
retour en 2002 alors que faustine
bollaert travaille pour le magazine télé
7 jours en tant que journaliste elle
tente de s'infiltrer dans le casting de
love story 2 pour révéler les coulisses
de l'intérieur invité hier de c'est à
vous elle est revenue sur cette histoire
et briser dans les 50 dernières j'ai été
démasqué alors on m'avait quand les
choses complètement absurde
je me souviens qu'un jour je m'arrête
demandait de simuler un an
garçons et donc j'avais j'ai fait un
très gros match une enquête qu'elle
avait livré dans les colonnes du
magazine et qui n'avait visiblement pas
plu à tout le monde
à l'époque un certain benjamin castaldi
à leurs animateurs du programme l'aurait
appelée pour lui expliquer sa façon de
penser à l'époque j'avais fait un gros
scandale je me souviens avoir cédé à ben
afan de benjamin castaldi qui m'avait
insulté qui vient alors qu'en est il
aujourd'hui entre les deux animateurs
tout va bien j'ai téléphoné avant-hier
pourrez alors vous allez mourir dans un
instant qu'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement ce qu'on veut tout savoir et
c'est pas moi qu'il faut savoir c'est
saïda